the LA YouTube culture is different from
the New York YouTube culture in that New
York does not have you to culture or the
culture is very very small it's just
that you can't even compare it it's I
was doing collaborations in New York
with youtubers across the country and
asking them to send me their footage and
then edit it into something and it's not
the same as being in a room with someone
and here I i find myself have a like
getting excited to talk about youtube
with youtubers because i can do a face
to face now and it's been really great
and collaborating has kind of gone
through the roof it there was one week
recently where I was literally doing a
collaboration video with someone every
single day of the week and it was a
suitable but it was also very cool
because then all those videos come out
it's like oh this is why it's nice to be
out here also I wore shorts in February
so that's a great change and there's
beautiful natural light here all the
time in New York the weather is is a
horrible and so it's you can't
depend on shooting outside at least when
I left I left right after Hurricane
sandy it was kind of like the final
you from New York to me as I left no
like thank you very much the exit II you
were a horrible horrible to me but
also nice I was auditioning for TV film
before i started doing youtube and about
a few months ago i booked a Lowe's
commercial that went on TV and it was a
series we shot eight commercials in
three days and everyone online that's
all it was like huh dailygrace and this
commercial lowes got Daily Grace when
really it's like they got grace Helbig
the actress that auditions for things it
wasn't like they saw my youtube videos
and plucked me from the internet the
YouTube videos almost didn't get me the
job because companies like to have
squeaky-clean spokesperson and some of
the videos are not squeaky clean lowes
almost didn't hire me because of a piece
that I shot with g44 attacked the show
after they disregarded it and put the
commercials up the social media return
on the commercials was so ecstatic and
so positive that they were like we love
grace she's great we love her forget
everything so have we to say anything we
were always grace grace grace and so I
think that they realized like the power
of the internet to help promote product
and that's why I think I could never
fully ever abandon the internet such a
great cool place and also a terrible
place the lowes audition was a really
memorable audition because it's one of
those auditions that I was like if I
don't book this this audition tape is
going to go online somewhere in like 20
years and people be like this is insane
the director really liked with
people so he wanted you to be an
to potential customers because they were
using real customers so you had to be
able to riff with them until they got
the sound bite that they needed for
their commercial and so he was having me
do crazy stuff like my energy like super
high he's like there are jets next to
pretend there are jets next to you and I
was like welcome to Loews brother Bella
and I was like making horrible puns and
just like screaming and I walked out the
audition room and all the girls that
were like ready to go in who at that
point in time this was in New York I
knew a lot of them because the comedy
scene is very tight-knit words just like
yeah we heard it sounded great yep that
was really embarrassing at every girl
that went in was like this I feel like
we're all getting pumped right now in
this audition then I ended up booking
the audition and the day we shot he was
like okay so everything that you did
audition don't do so we just got to play
it real like monitor so in the
commercial I'm just like the most
generic version of like try my love said
so it was one of those things are like
why did you make me do all of that then
and I think he just wanted to see that
someone would do what he said so that
table probably online at some point I
just had a moment the other day where I
went on an audition at ABC and I walked
into the room and it was for a pilot
that it was about three main girls and I
walked into a room of just about 20
girls all like beautifully dressed and
perfectly accessorize and I just started
laughing out loud it's just so silly
they were all sitting in this room
totally nervous and like wringing our
hands like oh god like waiting for this
godlike creature to judge us and either
choose us or not choose us and it's such
a thing then when you realize like oh no
one's forcing us to be in this crazy
emotionally taxing thing we've all
volunteered to be here it's just so
silly but coming to the end of pilot
season haven't booked anything but it's
been really pushing my desire to create
my own content which is what I've been
used to doing what I feel is my strong
suit so now I'm trying to kind of curve
my trajectory in a direction that allows
me to create possibly my own show
I think the comedy style it's not
mean-spirited silly goofy it's fun when
people ask me to describe dailygrace
because the audience tends to lean
towards teenage girls I say that Daily
Grace is your awkward older sister that
doesn't know everything about the world
but is trying to figure it out with you
and give you advice that might not be
the best but she's trying it's awkward
and and goofy and hopefully I'm
hopefully not annoying so what I tried
to steer clear of when I was younger I'm
the only girl and a family of brothers
and I thought my brothers were the
funniest people in the world so I had a
comedy inkling when I was younger
because I always wanted to make them
laugh and I remember the first time I
made them laugh is by doing a cartman
impersonation in the car when we were
driving on a family trip and I was like
yes this is the greatest feeling and so
I want to do that somehow and obviously
Tina Fey was one of the first people
that I thought was so so great and I
wanted to follow her career path as a
sketch writer and then maybe a performer
and so I was taking sketch writing
classes start a sketch team at my
college and an improv team we did a lot
of comedy stuff and it was really fun I
also think that Lisa Kudrow as Phoebe on
friends is one of the funniest
characters ever and I think there's a
real strong influence of that in Daily
Grace and when people comment on it I'm
like oh cool because I think that she
her characters just so funny and people
don't really realize it or don't think
about it in terms of like funny women
currently like people like Kristen Wiig
and Melissa McCarthy are just so
endlessly funny am i rude often Rachel
Dratch and they're so an Amy Poehler
they're just so so great and and so I've
definitely been influenced by then I
created a lot of content and it
sometimes I sit back and I look at it
I'm like whoa that's pretty cool that
I've done a lot of different ideas and
sometimes I sit back and I have the fear
of oh god one day it's the wells going
to run dry but the great thing about the
Internet
about it being a two-way street is that
I utilize Tumblr and Facebook and
Twitter and I ask people for ideas for
Wednesday reviews or how to soar what
kind of advice you need for like daily
advice episodes and it's been really
really great I think that's a part of
the success that delivers has had is
that there's a closest to the audience
because they help me make videos every
day your brain has this tendency to
remember pain more than pleasure which
is so fast age makes you'll read a
hundred great comments and then you'll
read one negative comment you'll
remember that negative comment word for
word but you couldn't quote any of the
other hundred you've read and it's just
something chemically I think that
happens that allows us to remember pain
and so I've learned by doing it so many
times that I'm not going to make
everyone happy people have issues that
they like to project onto other people
by typing it out and it might make them
feel good for a second that's fine I
can't take it personally if I took it
personally I wouldn't be able to ever
create anything it's hard to do but you
just have to let it slide and I just
like to picture them in a wood-paneled
basement living a very sad sad life and
then I'm fine and I feel bit it's so
hard because you want to like post it on
your blog and be like this versus the
idiot everyone yell at this person I
remember one time on a tumblr i did
respond to like a teenage girl leaving
me a mean comment and people like when
after her and i felt so horrible i felt
so so bad that I let a teenager get to
me as an adult that I made she shut down
her tumblr and I felt so so horrible
after that so I learned a very valuable
lesson they never fight it just let it
exists and it's a it's so easy to say
and so hard to do but you just have to
try try to make an effort to do it
you'll waste your time it's a waste of
time it's a waste of time
now I am working on getting through the
rest of pilot season I'm doing live
shows live comedy shows with Hannah Hart
and mamrie Hart at the meltdown theater
here in Los Angeles and we are trying to
take the show it's called no filter on
tour and we're hoping to go to a few
colleges across the united states and
and do some live comedy cuz memory and I
both come from comedy backgrounds I did
improv comedy in New York and she's done
sketch comedy at UCB and all around New
York as well and after that working on
some hopeful potential TV ideas and
maybe throw in a book idea in there and
I'm going to South by Southwest for a
couple days for my damn channel on
subway and it should be all in a little
really great time I'd like to be within
the world of television for this future
endeavor but utilizing YouTube at the
same time a lot of questions I get our
what's the future of TV and Internet
will they fight to the death or will
they have sex with each other and I
think that they need to have sex with
each other because neither one's going
to go away entirely but the idea of like
collaboration and supplemental content
on another platform I think is a smart
way to bring new life to old media so
that would be my goal is to create a
program that utilizes the digital media
and creates an experience for people
rather than just hey here's my content
on this wall look at it I want it to be
interactive in as many ways as it can be
what that is is to be determined I have
all the descriptions of it but I just
don't have it yet it can be very
intimidating to break into a comedy
space whether it's in traditional media
or on the internet because it's your
quote unquote a male-dominated field but
it doesn't matter the only thing that
matters in comedy is that you have a
point of view or an opinion or
perspective on the world that people can
either relate to or laugh at and so it
doesn't matter if you're a girl or a guy
it's just your point of view so work on
developing your point of view and your
voice that's the most
thing and your authenticity because
attention is currency online i heard
chris hardwick say this recently and it
really resonated with me and it's true
if you can get someone's attention it's
like they've paid you for your service
and I think that authenticity rings so
true online and people can see
your audience is smart even if they seem
dumb so just don't feed them be
authentic and find a point of view or
find something you're really passionate
about also you're passionate about two
different things combine them it's also
what i heard chris hardwick say so
basically just ask chris hardwick I
would really want to have Jennifer
Lawrence in a video and take a shot with
her I think she's doing that all of you
Oscar yeah she took a shot after the
Oscars and she was hilarious so I'd like
to have her I think in a Daily Grace
video even if she was just standing in
the back while I did a dilla grace video
and she was never talked to just to have
her presence there I think will be real
comforting to me I want Bobby if I could
have a cartoon character in a video I
want Bobby from king of the hill I think
he is the greatest created a cartoon
character of all time a flamboyant the
overweight boy from Texas is oh it's so
perfect I would love to have him in a
daily grace